[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by these
guys me undies the best most comfortable
sexual underwear you could get in
Valentine's Day is fast approaching
y'all not a better gift to be gotten
than me undies all right check the me
undies matching pairs collection for you
and your loved one Valentine by going to
me undies dot-com class Jenna Julian get
20% off your first time purchase of
matching pairs plus free shipping and
100% satisfaction guarantee what are you
guys waiting for the best Valentine's
gift is already available couldn't me
and these are common enjoy also a new
sponsor this week the wonderful DirecTV
now a great way to watch live TV over
the internet you can watch on your phone
or you can watch on the device like Roku
or Apple TV to stream to your TV
it is incredibly portable I like to
watch it all over the house you get a
whole bunch of channels okay at a very
affordable price $35 gets you over 60
live TV channels and it's month-to-month
okay you're not locked in it's great
check it out we go into DirecTV now comm
or click the link in our description
more on that later Thank You sponsors
well man I was up all night working on
that new theme song
you know scouring it and
scoring it talking to my mic to say
something in your mic sometimes get out
you can catch these hands if you do not
stop it we haven't even started well get
ready
oh man I'm pissed already you massacred
the beginning of our podcast to make it
the you podcast
well it isn't our podcast and I'm so
glad that I'm so glad you guys like the
new intro song and it was namely picked
up by John no one agreed to that no one
agreed they'd like some we end it with
the original names on our original like
dinked we'll just end it with that we'll
start with a new one end it with the old
one no oh I tried folks how are you
doing today just be me trying to like
backtrack from the beginning because
yeah cuz I'm down I'm like totally down
I'm already wide you've just started off
all hostile muscles my male name Julian
hostile follow me des mm like it's the
bait cast not like ruin the odd cast
what a way to set the scene my friends
for debate cast then starting a debate
right off the top right off the top
why don't we just let's start debating
oh that's a let's hop on into this ke
debate cast is where we take suggestions
and we debate over them like they're the
end of the world important very
meaningful topics meanwhile they're not
but we are treating them like they're
very meaningful and they're we're
treating them like they have wait so we
have a list of things that we have come
up with ourselves and also gotten from
you guys on Twitter make sure you're
following us
Jenna Julian on Twitter all right the
first one and we're gonna choose which
side choose and choose which side we
take on the spot does a straw have one
hole or two very hot topic so hard that
when you first said that it's a very hot
question debate what does a straw which
side are you taking have one hole or two
one I'm taking the one hole set it okay
let me know when you're ready
straw has two holes one on each end
put some closer together
how can you see I feel like you're gonna
hurt your eyes if you do that don't do
that everything's worth the price get
your bear cold foot off of me don't blow
up the spot of my foots temperature a
strong pulse one on the top and one on
the bottom they might be connected but
they're two holes
oh honey do you remember geometry do you
remember shapes yeah it's a cylinder
it's a cylinder cylinder has one hole
right down the middle it's standing up
like a cup with no bottom mm-hmm the
cylinder is the shape look at it like
this now looking through two holes
you're looking through the same [ __ ]
hole it is a long elongated shape with
long walls like that and you turn it
sideways and there's one hole there's
one hole then why aren't they connected
why are there two separate ends it's
like a hole if the hole where you got
get cotton-like define hole well the
whole argument is about whether or not
define all Oh fine I'll define huh hey
Siri defined hole
holy place in a solid body or surface do
you want to hear the next one a hollow
place in a solid body or surface yeah
hollow place mm-hmm it looks like it
looks like it was a ring right I don't
have an example right here okay you guys
can see this because we have a macro
lens right here okay so you put that on
here okay imagine if this was like this
was put in like a wormhole and it got
stretched out mm-hmm and now is the
cylinder it's still the same shape it's
just elongated and there's two ends to
every hole this is really hard to argue
wait you're actually onto something most
holes have one end [ __ ] like if you dig
a hole into the ground mm-hmm it's over
that's it that's why I said define hole
oh is it hollow on the other end because
in in theory they're both hollow on both
sides so they're both holes I don't even
understand my argument anymore
I've I thought I was clear but the thing
is it's like you shoot you're finding
the middle part as the hole hold on each
end as the hole go ahead go ahead there
is a hole on both ends right on the back
of the wall and on the front of I'm not
gonna so hole can exist with an entry
and exit point or with just an entry
point uh-huh is that right or wrong
that's correct okay
I think well it's correct that's correct
I know that's correct yeah okay so this
would just be an example of a hole with
an entry in an exit point
mm-hmm so you're just looking at it from
the other side but I'm defining the hole
as if you looked at a wall with a bullet
hole through both sides
one side would be a hole but the other
side also is the same hole yeah I would
never refer to it as two separate holes
that's two separate perspectives because
it's four perspectives yeah listen
listen if there's a halt on the Berlin
Wall before it got taken down one person
sees one side they say it's a hole and
the other person sees the other side say
hey look at that hole they're too old
they're two people seeing the same hole
from different places
look at his straw you don't look at a
straw hey thanks for my deku through the
straw you've popped up don't look
through and say oh there's a hole and
then flipped around saying oh wow what a
coincidence there's a hole on the other
side of it to it it's the same hole it's
one okay I think you're right this is
very difficult to argue that there are
two holes but I mean it's funny you
wouldn't write good debate welcome back
stop touching right here thank you for
waiting wow that we had commercial break
what makes a good sandwich okay this has
a lot more room for I would say debating
than just like arguing a specific point
so I'm gonna let you start cuz this was
your idea
I feel like to me really quick no no I'm
interrupting a back story today we were
at the Getty Museum and we were leaving
and Donna says I want a sandwich so here
we are
I want to subscribe to this channel and
I want it now I feel like a good
sandwich is like the right because I
obviously had vegan cheese and vegan ham
but I've always felt the same way that I
rather have like almost double the
amount of cheese than the amount of meat
because I don't like like a lot of meat
on a sandwich and almost nothing else on
it like if it's peanut butter and jelly
maybe you could throw some chips don't
like something crunchy in there chips on
peanut butter jelly yeah it's so good
but like nothing else you know first
sandwich I like I like things more
simple than I think people sell in like
a sandwich shop there's like onion and
tomato and lettuce and like it's piled
up really high whereas I'm just like I'd
like a couple things in a sandwich and
like a piece of bread and no one will
sell me a sandwich I don't like like a
nice cross-section of ingredients are
you kidding me no even okay here's the
other thing for me that makes amateur no
mayonnaise ever
unless it's a BLT and then it's just a
thin little layer of mayonnaise no I'm
not a mayonnaise damn thick layer Mayo
much including PB&J or die no that's
gross I would never do that okay I think
if you're having sandwiches with only
mustard mm-hmm me you need to wake up
No and literally quite literally smell
than I know don't touch me okay
I think Mayo is great on sandwiches yeah
I got like a club sandwich a BLT even a
club sandwich for a BLT really good with
me oh okay sandwiches with mayo you put
cream cheese on sandwiches yeah you know
crazy dude I [ __ ] I live once and I
act like it okay I want to say something
the cross-section thing is an important
point for me because if you're gonna
make a sandwich and all you're just
trying to skimp out on everything just
so you could have like a flat weird kind
of like boring amazing you're cutting in
half and you're all you're doing is
opening up disappointment that's all
you're doing and then you have to taste
the disappointment and then you have to
live with it inside of you my thing is
if you're making a sandwich pop out the
red onion pop out the tomatoes grab a
little lettuce you know put it on there
get a nice little layer of cheese a
little extra lunch meat your faux meat
or whatever you're doing then maybe add
some chips don't add chips to a PB&J
that's absolutely that's don't enough
it's like a nice salty crunch you ever
put Cheetos like in their PB&J
yeah Doritos you're you're combining
sweet with like cheese yeah it's really
good I'm when I was not here I don't I'm
not sitting here right now when I was a
kid but ER and pickle sandwiches or
peanut butter and you just lost the
argument by saying that banana
I feel like PB and a5 [ __ ] with for me
personally the more simple the sandwich
the better like if it has more than four
ingredients I'm probably not going to
enjoy it okay
my only exception to that rule is a
grilled cheese that's a simple sandwich
it's cheese and butter not one of the
day
it's like a grilled cheese it's like not
even a thing of its own no it's that's a
sandwich so I'm saying okay right what
we just went to the grocery store came
home Jenna made a sandwich with bread
mustard like faux ham faux cheese that's
it emanated amazing and it was like flat
as a [ __ ] iPhone I couldn't even look
at it cuz when she turned it sideways it
disappeared I look I I had more lunch me
than she did I had tomatoes I had
lettuce I had onion
I threw some chips on there what I'm
feeling wild oh do I'll do like a double
stack you know like you do the the third
layer and then maybe pay and you crunch
it down and you cut it up and you open
it up and you're like wow that's an
amazing thing I just created that now
I'd get to enjoy the fact that you like
small flat sandwiches yeah more than big
like exciting sandwiches I will give you
that sometimes at restaurants they're
overdoing but look at our big club
sandwich and it's like you can't take a
bite out yeah I get that that's that's
that's that's extract toughen up the
roof your mouth that's extra though
excuse you I think there is a little
happy medium we could find here and
instead of one of us winning the
argument we can just like stop the
podcast and go make sandwich I feel like
if given the choice unless it's a BLT
which is like the only exception I would
not want to order a sandwich with
lettuce on it idea let's let's agree on
three sandwiches that we can agree on
our like three great sandwiches and
we'll decide out of the three which ones
are more flat and which ones are more
tall and that person wins
so grilled cheese is one of them grilled
cheese is one right peanut butter and
jelly no I didn't agree to that club
club club sandwiches I do so why do you
get to two just named three simply chess
but it will fit your argument
you saw me eat a club sandwich boy you
probably drunk when we were in the club
no no cheese like a golf club it's
definitely from is it a night club it's
not a night club
all right so grilled cheese mm-hmm BLT
peanut butter and jelly all over Essex
those are not all flat BLT is not flat
yes LT is a thick [ __ ] one piece of
lettuce one tomato a little thin layer
of mayo when did you see the BLT where
did you see the BLT with the middle
smaller than both of its ends that's how
your sandwiches look it's just like BLT
have you seen it let's look up a picture
literally right now BLT it's flat no
it's not make it nice and flat
LT sandwich on some nice toast no you're
out of here you're out of your gourd
okay how does that look flat to you
that's just someone's interpretation in
a half [ __ ] avocado okay that's
that's a normal BLT that is not flat
that is not flat I know you can see it
is a great view I don't know how we're
gonna settle this here all right what's
the next one we'll agree to disagree for
now let us know in the comments because
I'm bright sandwiches are delicious when
they're simple yeah Geoff don't yeah me
whatever yeah I want the comments let us
know who won that one who is better
calling her rum all right how will we
choosing which side to argue here well I
think the tuna Rochambeau four sides
okay better gets winner gets who know
you got to decide all right okay here's
what we're gonna do Pete get off the
telly are we gonna do first
can you help mama why cuz I need to flip
something else can myself if my phone
lands screen side up just one sec here
if my phone lands through screen side up
it's rum and if it screen side down it's
calling that's what we're gonna
Rochambeau for for the winner Colin so
the winner of Rochambeau gets Colin you
mean has to argue that Colin is better
than okay Shambo its Rock Paper Scissors
shoo I pointed at you know Rock Paper
Scissors shoot no ropes JimBob let's
argue that are we breaking up it's Rock
Paper Scissors shoot shoot it's not it's
called The Rock Paper Scissors there's
no shoot in the name why would you why
would you add an extra step look at what
it's created for this whole conversation
where it's extraneous dude it's rock
paper scissors and that's alright fine
you want to do it that way rock rock
paper scissors rock paper scissors
[Music]
paper scissors I have to argue they are
evil Rome yeah oh man alright um you
gotta give me something here here we go
colin is better than rome because he's
just an eccentric guy out here wearing
shorts like there's no tomorrow he's
funny he's got cool hair yeah but have
you heard him talk
Rome is way cooler when it comes to her
voice she has a very exotic voice that's
from Australia it's when the first time
you hear it you say whoa and then boom
you have a relationship and you have a
new friend and her name is Rome hmm
because of that she does something with
her mouth when she talks it makes it
come out different and it's truly
fascinating and just an eighth wonder of
our world she has a jewelry line she's
their daughter but the daughter looks
more like Rome than it does Bowie looks
more like round that's all up for debate
it's literally not Colin is better I'm
interested to see where you go at this
point
: also has an accent it's like a
Southern California accent if we live
inside out for you you don't call that
an accent that's just that's the if
someone else heard him speak they'd be
like that's quite the exit if people in
Australia heard Colin speak they they'd
like his accent so the same argument can
be made for Colin just not here so are
we arguing basically like California
versus Australia no Colin is better than
Rome the
cuz call can call and make a piece of
jewelry while I didn't think he could
call me from Ken Collins an ideas guy
Collins better at Twitter he tweets all
bad he does do that
god this is hard here's what we're going
to do what what
Rome is is a snapchat goddess she
doesn't use snapchat I use it with her
and she gives my snapchat just content
when I'm able to snapchat her my
snapchat goes from cool and like normal
snapchat to like mm-hmm
you know what are you entertained right
now TV a because I'm watching a grown
woman be so annoyed that I'm going to
snap at any given thing live on snapchat
Collin doesn't do that because if I try
dudes call him he just got he plays with
the joke and he goes along with it and
then he's he's the guy being funny Rome
doesn't let you do that
honestly you win Rome is better than
Collin we have no winner we have no
clear winners the real winner here
ladies and gentlemen is Bowie because we
are fighting and her parents are now
fighting because of us you're welcome
everyone right what else you got
that's a small animal who just left
we're both the small one okay noodles
versus rice what are you doing excuse me
as the latter I'm not on it's not a
ladder all right which side are you
taking Jillian come here
which side do you want to take no you
have to decide noodles all right I'll
take rice my first argument is rice is
better than noodles because rice can be
noodles noodles can't be rice [ __ ] beat
that yeah I guess your favorite pasta
dish was probably a risotto ha that's
what someone who likes rice would say
more than noodles no my favorite noodle
this is rice noodles so you don't like
anytime your favorite dish and the whole
world is me you're Lily's proving your
point it's made with new rice a type of
noodles which it doesn't matter what's
in the noodles noodles no rice it's made
with rice don't spit over there that's
not no noodles are the final product
uh-huh
does it matter what's in them you don't
say ooh are you okay you don't say I
like eggs because eggs are in cake you
say I like cake you don't credit the
final form with one ingredient of it
rice noodles have been they've gone
through a lot to get to where they are
and now their noodles and now they're
great and they are in the family of some
of the best foods are people as human
beings on this planet earth know how to
enjoy which is pasta and noodles every
Italian pasta dish - aside from risotto
which come at me Gordon Ramsay it's not
as good as pasta comes from noodles
think of every possible like mm-hmm
pasta dish penne alla vodka mm-hmm
Alfredo mac and cheese what are you
gonna do without noodles nothing you're
gonna do nothing you're gonna have no
dish anymore you're gonna be stuck with
pad thai every night imagine that it's
like your life right now it's my reality
wins every time
rice rice is one ingredient of one type
of noodles rice feeds more people in the
world than it's cheap it's not expensive
you can have a billion of it at a time
no that's an unfair as unfair everybody
knows you can eat rice and never gain
weight
it's basically celery what are you
watching The Cooking Channel on DirecTV
now and your phone is
you know that did you just say because
right now you can watch The Cooking
Channel too and watch so many other
channels guys 60 live TV channels right
from your device or you can stream to
the TV it's great okay
one of my favorite things about DIRECTV
now because I get to watch TV over the
Internet
on my time I can watch SVU
from the bathroom if I want no one's
gonna tell me I can't not even her
okay straight to your TV or your tablet
or your device and you can stream it
with Apple TV or Roku
they have top channels like ESPN Disney
news channels sports live sports all
right you don't need to be sitting down
you know in a room with a bunch people
you don't be with you just grab your
phone go be antisocial and watch it
there I was high TV on your phone with
DirecTV now there's no long term
contract like I said guys that is so
gross move the mic away from his mouth
no there's no long-term contract its
month-to-month guys it's so clunky to
have boxes everywhere cable boxes and
satellites just do it on your phone
DirecTV now that's all you need check it
out okay try it see how you like it you
won't believe how affordable it is for
what you're getting
you go to DirecTV now com check it out
he's like one of the nastiest animals
I've ever seen with my eyes you guys
think that this is bad like he does this
all the time
any general sit down anywhere he'll find
whatever spot of her leg is like bear
and lick it oh so Wow so [ __ ] loud
loud like the cool designs of me undies
that you can get for Valentine's Day to
match with your significant other or
Valentine the me andis Valentine's
matching line is coming out soon it's
actually right now and you can get it
for Valentine's Day what are you waiting
for Valentine's Ace next month it's not
gonna surprise you you know the date
February 14th right
no no no no February 14th
guys it's fast approaching are you gonna
want to fall behind and be like a schlub
and run to the store and get some
flowers and chocolates they'll give you
that no you want to get some me a tease
to match with your partner or your
friend or your Valentine or whatever
they are to you it's so cute
check it out right now and this is like
the perfect time of year for me and ease
this is like my favorite time to promote
me and ease I love me and ease and I
will promote them all year long but
Valentine's Day y'all is like their it's
their [ __ ] it's their Superbowl it's
their thing ok so check it out me and
these calm slots Jenna chillin 20% of
your first order and that includes the
matching pairs cool designs and if you
you for some reason already have your
Valentine's gift covered you spent a
whole bunch of money on something else
that's fine year-round me undies is
coming out with new designs really cool
prints the most comfortable underwear in
the world three times softer than cotton
deliver to your door check it out
Mandy's not cops necessarily are you
done I like I'm gonna throw up I'm gonna
throw up on the podcast on our brand new
Mike something to throw you can't it's
like can I get some support in the
comments like I feel like I'm literally
a crazy person for not liking that
that's that's weird
he's my kissy guy he is he's wrong he is
wrong
that's our showers which side are you
taking whatever side you don't want
showers showers are better than baths I
do not want to sit in a pile of my own
crud sorry I'm gonna the the most
comfortable position known to the human
why are you bad showers yeah the most
comfortable position known to mankind oh
and I can clean myself while I'm doing
it
you're never clean when you take a bath
God how convenient I'm
asleep now oh how relaxing all I just
took a nap I'm resting that's how you
drown Julian and I'm alive you can't
drown in the shower I'm I'll have you
absolutely can you can drown in the
shower no excuse me you're interrupting
my peaceful laying down in a bowl of
human-sized bowl of water doing people
in ancient times you take baths it's a
little outdated we take showers it's
more sanitary you don't have to sit in a
pile of your own crud you wash your hair
what your body gives off but my body
does not give off crud that is a lie it
does not boy you filthy I I am filthy I
will take that I am a filthy person but
I when I take a bath mm-hmm something
happens y'all I don't even know how to
explain it
I just I'm laying there there's likely a
bath bomb look over to the side I see my
clean pair of me and he said I'm gonna
jump in when I'm done and I'm just
floating no you're not I'm floating I am
boy fully 100% boy it's not like the
five physics in the bathroom because of
how magical it is see when you enter the
bath go along that's it that's our
sentence you don't you have a long hard
day at work yeah they're real hard at
work why don't I do some more standing
while I clean how convenient that is I'm
gonna just stand up faster than about
its way fast
sit up in the bath that's sitting how
comfortable is that everybody loves
sitting you can have a bench in your
shower and sit seat no that's a bath no
what is it that's about a seat in the
shower is a bath
absolutely not about it is a seat in a
shower is a back are literally
surrounded by water yeah and as you sit
down it pools like in between your legs
so you're in like a mini bath
anything you make [ __ ] up just in the
shower does not make it a bath
absolutely not I got something for you
what when you were a kid and your parent
was being you and they took the pitcher
they poured over your head you're gonna
deprive yourself of those memories what
are you talking now give you those
amazing fun baths yeah because you're a
tiny person that can barely stand up
that's why you can't take a shower
good luck bathing a tiny person who
can't stand up in a [ __ ] chamber with
flying water everywhere the only reason
they take the water and go like this
over your head it is to make it more
like a shower so you get your baby clean
if you win this argument if you if you
if you win this argument
we will never bathe our kid we will only
shower them and that's gonna be your
fault and it's gonna be difficult and
they're gonna be hating every no I agree
these times and places for baths and
showers but you know what's better you
ever um you ever hear someone who's
stressed out say uh I'm gonna go
upstairs and
you're lying I'm you're right I am lying
in the bath showers are better and and
Julian just because you know I'm so
relaxed I feel like a new human I feel
like I'm a new human and I'm gonna sit
here facing you directly this way for
the rest of the podcast to play that
game
okay so who won that well I don't know
do you like flying water pelting you all
over the body yes you do
yeah do you agree that when we have a
kid they will only be showered or not
based no okay I have a question I have a
question I have a question I have a
question I have a question that pumps
what they're just gonna be useless
inventions now you can still take a bath
but showers are better so okay I have a
question if you're saying showers are
better
that means bath bombs are irrelevant to
the better choice you can't take a bath
bomb in the shower every goddamn person
knows that no you can't you can't no you
can't you can you can do anything you
put your mind to all right fine I'm not
respond to that what's that I think we
have one more which x-men is the best
[Music]
which x-men is the best um what we all
know is that [ __ ] Jubilee because she
can barely follow basic rules and
commands over him I say probably storm
is my favorite storm Wolverine has
lasted through centuries he doesn't age
he's all nearly the best yourself
healing I think storms the best oh she
is the best hair easily Oh what is that
oh great yeah it's raining let's go
inside it's not gambit can we agree on
that
gambit can go [ __ ] himself he is not the
best hello we said that my video and
everyone in the comments was like he
couldn't even summon kinetic energy and
he can make his cards into explosive he
basically make anything blow up he's
like yeah he's still a magician just
looking for a group of friends yeah to
the x-men purists who were trying to
prove us again that was a word the x-men
we still think he's not a word the x-men
yeah true give him grenades or power and
to put in a little object or explain in
the comments why gambit is the best
x-men oh no one can because he's not
well no well aside from all the ladies
that have a crush on yes he's not that
he is he does get the ladies he does get
baby
so I think Wolverines the best men I
think storing these I think storm is
storm is like you know just the flashy
Instagram x-men the one that shows off
like the cool looking but Michael hours
you posted on Instagram you put a filter
on it maybe a little time lapse of it
you like how that looks that was cool
like that's visually interesting but
does it really help anyone on the team
no it doesn't it just distracts everyone
in fact some of their x-men practices
get rained out because storm is having a
little bit storm like an Instagram model
oh yeah
no tea no shade just sex
yeah the tea is hot because it's
freezing and raining around because of
storms like that bleached hair and like
all of storms of her looks like come on
do you think fighting fighting evil and
crime and training as x-men in the
school of the gifted or is that what
it's called do you think she has time to
go get that [ __ ] touch that no dude it's
a hashtag ad bro
what about Professor X I I think you're
talking about jean-luc Picard nice no
Trekkie yet
Trekkie Captain jean-luc god USS
Enterprise Captain zombie God USS
enterprise data is my ideal man see you
guys next week Amy do you need me here
for any of this okay yeah I mean you win
I can't I can't argue that storm is
better than Wolverine because you just
you poked a giant flaw in my argument
thank you I mean it makes sense right
yeah yeah yep she even has those like
movie contacts I for make her eyes white
either clearly from like a film and TV
store i forfeit hashtag odd also know
penny and also I already won okay are we
arguing or anything else
yep rice seasoning No Oh which x-men is
the worst no preseason no what what else
you know Oh
the grand finale we of debate cast will
be the office versus
Seinfeld I have one thing to say to this
if you just google them you can't do
that just Google that can't do that
yes debate not at Google if you just
google then on IMDB Seinfeld has an
eight point nine out of ten and the and
the office has an eight point eight okay
wasn't the office like so you like the
American office right because the
original office was over my IMDB you
mean the site that rated your favorite
movie the jerk a seven point - yeah what
a reliable source that movies at least a
ten exactly so why would it have a seven
point two on a corrupt website like IMDB
corrupt it's corrupt don't use that as a
source just proving that wrong just cuz
you love something doesn't mean it can't
have a bad score on there okay Seinfeld
score is still better than the offices
the offices of worldwide sensation why
don't you like the European because it's
it was literally just the spark that
created what needed to be created which
is a u.s. office anyone who likes the UK
office more in the US office is is
either a very UK true person to like UK
entertainment and doesn't like an
American entertainment or just is
stubborn and wrong because the US office
is amazing well you know what Seinfeld
was a spin off of nothing dude it's not
a spin office [ __ ] [ __ ] it's literally
an original creation they took the
nation by storm it's an amazing litmus
test slowly the laughing Seinfeld or you
can get the [ __ ] out
please stop winning greatest show of
this argument stop it you're winning too
much please stop it
iconic okay it's an iconic show and they
ended it before it got all weird and
stupid what are you implying the office
got weird and stupid while it was in its
late phase
yeah it it lost its main main main
attraction and still lived on to be a
beautiful did it though beautiful ending
of a series it still live on it did
haven't I heard the words there is no
office without Steve Carell come out of
your mouth no no how do you put those
words into my mouth what about the later
seasons when he wasn't on mission they
were great it evolved there were new
characters it evolved then why isn't it
still on cuz it ended what end I think
it ended a little too late listen I
think they let that horse bleed out
listen here listen all I gotta say is at
least Steve Graham John McCarthy was the
referee of that television show it would
have been over two rounds before head
god it was clearly a knockout when Steve
Carell left the show okay at least you
don't see Steve Carell driving around
his car drinking coffee trying to be hip
on the Internet
hang in my car we'll go get coffee and
film and put it on YouTube well you
don't believe enough of your own
platform to stay there stay there just
like Steve Carell did film and TV for
life till he dies really no internet
really I think you're just biased
because you never made it through all of
science you never made it through all
the office so where we know I don't need
to say this I've seen Seinfeld that
doesn't make any my dog is named after
Seinfeld uh-huh we have a goofy friend
George
[Laughter]
Jerry pulls pulls [ __ ] raises goofy
[Music]
I've tilted you
fine do you want to see me do the other
guys we live in New York you I mean you
want to see me do the office ha ha ha
Kramer's crazy fine
I'm Jim could you not tell that was it
those this is my comedic ability yet I
say something you know smug and whatever
and then I just look into the camera and
I make millions of dollars no [ __ ]
reason garbage the whole show all the
writing has been influenced by yeska
Seinfeld came before the office does not
mean it was influenced by I want you to
get out get out the original show about
nothing didn't exist the office which is
also really kind of about nothing would
not exist the office is about something
it's about nothing no it's not about
it's I know you're talking about I know
Seinfeld is a brilliant show and that
it's about nothing and it still is
amazing timeless classic but the office
took something that almost every
American goes through in a workplace
environment a shitty nine-to-five boring
office job and made it into something
that is so [ __ ] relatable and
hilarious and cringy at the same time
but also like brilliant that okay so
what about every other workplace comedy
that existed before that show nothing
like the office let's take office space
I know but it's still a piece of
entertainment let's compare the two
really quick okay one's iconic and one
semi iconic yeah the office is iconic
office spaces so many iconic Wow
absolutely iconic was a computer printer
what was it copier a copier printer yes
copier sorry okay it's not iconic it was
a great movie the office is still like
too early to be iconic it's mama
disagree disagree there's pockets of
people that are influenced by it's not
a cultural thing within America yeah
yeah you're right because it's not the
most mainstream thing in the world which
means which means Seinfeld is better no
because there's a lot of stupid people
in the world no not gonna do this you
know how does it feel in the world just
look at what I needed to stop myself
there's a lot of sick people in the
world so just because the office isn't
as worldwide of a phenomenon a
nationwide generation no the people who
like the office are onto something why
do you think Jerry Seinfeld rides around
in his car and gets coffee with people
on he's desperate and trying to be
relevant on the internet cuz this man
literally has to work no more days in
his life then why isn't he just ride
around getting coffee without [ __ ]
filming it because he likes to laugh
[Music]
ty no Alfred you that was your only
chance Julian if the office is better
hmm
then Seinfeld why didn't you name your
dog after the show I'm sorry what
nothing less sister did the same thing
she named her dog after her favorite
show all right you know I don't you mean
detective Olivia Benson
well now it's lieutenant she changed on
Instagram last night because I told her
like you got to change puppies it's
lieutenant Benson now who would I've
named her Pam Beesly come here Pam
Beesly it doesn't roll off the tongue
Kelly come here Kelly it's gonna sound
like I'm talking to Kelly like the
person and doesn't make sense I named a
five-pound Chihuahua mr. marbles well if
I had a five months ago I might have
named him pee pee pee paw paw I get that
on the show we just shared it off as
master this moment was brought to you by
the officer Julian that might be a funny
joke but it will never stand your hand
you see Lee Jerry or any of the other
idiot far phone idiot farfel farfel is
pretty good fusilli Jerry fusilli Jerry
Festivus a bro a man's ear absolutely
not
let go of that get out of here you're
gonna leave you're wrong all right I
okay here's what's gonna happen
here's this gonna happen TV continues
okay and this wall okay ABC TV see but
I'll be fair this is a debate cast so we
have two heatedly debate our side yeah a
lot of what we said guys please put down
the pitchforks slowly put them down and
in the orderly fashion that we might
have said were extreme but it was in the
name of protecting what we believe is
best which is the office and this the
bay cast is all about getting no don't
play it don't play it I swear to god no
no no no look at the theme song for both
of them which has more views does
Seinfeld have a shitty flute I didn't
think so
I hear oh that's funny
[Music]
wonderful Julian on YouTube the first
thing that comes up as Seinfeld has like
five million views and the first thing
that comes up if you type in the office
theme song
it only has five thank you for watching
this a bit of fun podcast sounds like we
all know the more iconic song here and
it just so happens to be okay it's kind
of laughs alright but here's what's
gonna happen
this is TBC we need to figure out a way
to settle this
we need to figure out a way to settle
this that's not the bait cast cuz the
bait cast goes nowhere but it heads over
and over we need you guys to give us
some ideas in the comments of how we can
oh my god how we can settle this office
vs. Seinfeld how we as a couple and a
and a team here can settle this cuz
there is a way to settle this I just
don't know what it is congratulations on
your arguments how about we can bond
over this now can we bond over this yes
we can the song brings everyone together
wait hold on ding-ding-ding-ding
ding-ding-ding-ding ding-ding-ding-ding
that was too fast dink dink dink dink
dink dink dink ding ding ding ding
good debating thank thank you for the
debates yeah thank you guys for watching
and listening to our debates
we'll be back with another episode next
week when we do something that I don't
know what it is right now but please
leave us your comments on all of these
debates and just on the floor pitch
books on the floor just just feel so
disrespected that you said this is
George I know how to go for the jugular
okay I know I know what I'm doing here
in this debate cast anyway guys thanks
so much for hanging out see you guys
[Music]
you